what else what have we talked about
recently I I remember did everybody
speak about House of dragon I watched
that that was really I've started
watching that it's so good yeah it's so
so good what's that it's um
okay is it complicated no it's it's um
uh pretty cool but it's sort of connect
is a Game of Thrones but it sort of is
sort of it's like 300 400 years before
Game of Thrones do I have to watch Game
of Thrones no no no not at all it's
really good and it's got Matt Smith and
he's really getting it Matt Smith is
Great Net he's [ __ ] awesome he's so
good I think I'm like three episodes in
right now it's I don't know how you
could watch three episodes and be like
I'll come back to this it's it's it's
okay it's so good it's so good oh God
God forbid we have all this [ __ ] going
on but no like it's so good that it's
like I I would not be able to rest until
I've continued watching everything right
now all right I mean it reminds me of
like early Game of Thrones We're not
gonna bring up this like can of worms
again right because oh yeah guys
I remember I remember Charlie was
talking about remember when filmed the
Charlie episode he was like yeah I think
like I think like anime fans are pretty
chill I I think like film and TV fans
are the most toxic I was like ah I don't
know Charlie and then the [ __ ]
episode came out your take was so
colossally [ __ ] that I think everyone
across the board I think even people
who've never watched Game of Thrones are
like I don't it's probably God because I
I look back at it I'm like yeah I still
I still agree with that take because
it's because I didn't even okay here's
the here's the thing that confuses me
right here's the thing doesn't confuse
me I didn't even say that I I didn't
even say that I thought the first like
half Game of Thrones was better I just
said I preferred like the latter half of
Game of Thrones you might as well say
the same thing there's a big [ __ ]
diff okay okay here's
it okay go on explain yourself I will
explain I will explain myself okay I
will explain myself I will okay you're
wrong okay so
uh I I think I mentioned this briefly in
a recent video I did but to me I value
stuff more like even if it's not
perfectly executed versus something that
might be highly claimed highly like very
very well executed that doesn't appeal
to me the reason the reason the latter
half of the Game of Thrones appealed to
me more than the early seasons of Game
of Thrones is in the early season of
Game of Thrones great writing great
television okay but a lot of the stories
in Game of Thrones it was it wasn't like
five stories that are in Connected there
were like five separate stories so you
had the stories going with he had the
story with King's Landing the story with
Daenerys the story up on the wall
they're all really interesting stories
but they were all like their own kind of
individual stories in that sense and
what really interests me and what I love
seeing in what I love what I value and
what I love seeing is different elements
kind of like colliding in together so I
the thing I was waiting for in Game of
Thrones was to see these separate
entities these separate elements start
colliding in together yeah and then I
still really really appreciated the
first four seasons of Game of Thrones
but when I really really started to get
interested was you know uh when Tyrion
you know got shipped off to Daenerys and
I was like oh okay we're seeing one
character interact with another
character and then and then elements
Stark lines together and I found that
interesting and then you know when I'm
not gonna say season eight was [ __ ]
even close to great it was [ __ ] okay
when I say I prefer the latter Seasons
everything but season eight season eight
was [ __ ] yeah but like season six and
season seven I would say they were they
were a bit messy they weren't well
executed but they had elements in them
that I was waiting to see for Game of
Thrones this entire time and just I I
you know I can say that I think the
first four seasons were better written
but I can also say that even though the
latter seasons were more messily
executed had worse writing I still I
still see them as very very entertaining
television I still see them because I I
think the reason people clown on the
later season so far so much is because
the first four seasons were so [ __ ]
good right yeah I mean so I'll explain
this without spoiling anything without
you know going into too much detail
um so the the you mentioned that like
they're all individual stories about
that because the way it works Jerry is
that Game of Thrones will like be like
here's here's this scene where it's
happening at this location right and
then another scene in this location
across the other side of the country
yeah and so it was like God said it was
building up to that stuff was kind of
gradually they were kind of intertwining
yeah and the first three or four seasons
there's stuff happening and it tended to
be quite insular but there would be
stuff that happened quite a lot that
would have Rippling effects I think the
reason why people like Game of Thrones
so much was that if any other writer had
had written it it you know they it would
have
that when something happened in Game of
Thrones it was very like Slow Burn and
minute how it would Ripple but but
everything was into consideration if
somebody did or said something it would
have such a like really subtle effect or
every single like
yeah there was every single interaction
was so carefully considered yeah and I I
what really pissed off a lot of fans is
that one after the like season four it
kind of went to like okay these
characters just fundamentally just
changed like they just weren't writing
them the same as they were in the first
four seasons they weren't as intelligent
they started becoming more dumbed down
and also like travel became really
really fast as well so before in in Game
of Thrones traveling it would genuinely
take like maybe a season for someone to
travel right yeah or maybe a few
episodes
um and even then that might have been
too fast right like yeah I it was it was
all very subtle and very very realistic
it was meant to be like a serious
political drama where if you said
something and pissed off the wrong
person maybe in a season no two when
they when they go to somewhere else it
might have a ramification right yeah
every single thing was taken into
consideration all the counter
interactions were so perfect and then in
season five six seven eight it started
getting dumber and dumber and dumber and
like you mentioned like like there's a
character called Tyrion who was
typically quite smart and he becomes a
[ __ ] stupid idiot in like the past in
the past like three seasons at the end
he just becomes dumb and and is com the
complete different character to what he
was written as originally so people were
pissed off because all the characters
got stupider and and none of the like
the ramifications were happening it was
just kind of like duh big fight happened
now and then characters would suddenly
have a lot more plot armor than before
and some of the characters sitting down
to the lowest common denominator yeah
because one of the one of the things
that Game of Thrones did really well if
you haven't seen it is that when a
character would be in a fight they had
written it so well that you genuinely
didn't know who was gonna live and die
yeah like there was the plot armor was
never transparent it was never like
apparent sorry and you never felt like
someone could 100 live just because they
were this character yeah because the
first season sets it up that hey you
know characters are gonna die right away
like characters that you thought were
the main person or characters you
thought were very important to the story
will die yeah and towards the end it was
like this is the main character they
will not die yeah and no matter what
situation we put them in you can be
pretty sure that then there's not going
to be consequences and I think so it
became less like a a very very thought
out written TV show and kind of went to
a triple A Hollywood movie where we know
the main guy wins at the end yeah and I
think that was the problem like it went
down to like a regular formula that
everyone's yeah because even the writers
they said like publicly they were like
hey we want to make it so that some like
a football player who doesn't care about
fantasy can enjoy right and it was like
okay so yeah the writers just fully
admit that they dumbed it down yeah like
it just went dumb and yes those moments
that everyone was waiting for these big
fights and these big like collidings of
Worlds and all of these like kind of
rivalries coming out to play would have
been [ __ ] amazing if they were
written correctly oh no but they won but
obviously they were still it was still
as a fan who would probably watched Five
Seasons a part of you is still like oh
this is still kind of cool like you're
still like this the battles you're like
it's kind of hype and do you think that
happened because like the fan base got
more like I guess more generalized
because there's a few reasons so there's
a few reasons one is that they kind of
ran out of books to uh adapt yeah and
the books only went to about halfway you
could see such a big shift in the
writing from when they just ran out of
materials because uh I believe Joe R
Martin gave him like gave them the
Baseline of where the story yeah
but not like the nuances right yeah yeah
so I you know I I look at this latest
season of Game of Thrones and I'm like
where these character ends up where
these characters end up make sense story
wise how they ended up there does not
make sense at all yeah you know a lot of
things were also mentioned and then
never brought up again yeah and also
they had requested I can't remember it
was supposed to be 10 seasons yeah and
for some reason it ended up being eight
yeah and so they rushed to feel you feel
that it's eight like but even with how
bad the writing was I I don't know if it
even would have still been good by the
end of it because it was so [ __ ]
yeah I mean I see I I don't I don't
think it was [ __ ] I think like okay but
if season 8 was hot garbage dude see
okay season that hot Garbage I'd say
season five it was yeah five five to
seven it's like a solid eight eight hour
turn seven was not good seven was not
good I don't like seven either I think I
think five is where you start to see the
cracks six is where it starts to get
worrying seven is where you're like oh
oh it's ruined and then eight is like oh
God oh God oh God it was so bad it was
really it was horrible could you imagine
that you've been with something for like
12 10 years of your life and then right
at the end they're like let's just [ __ ]
it all up let's make it [ __ ] and and I
thought I genuinely thought I was like
I'm over Game of Thrones I'm done I
don't care about this world anymore yeah
I'm I I do not yeah and then House of
dragons started it's so good and it made
me realize just how amazing like the
world of Game of Thrones is and I'm sure
people watching this don't give a [ __ ]
about Game of Thrones but generally the
world is so interesting I think it's one
of if not my favorite like fantasy world
it is it is I think the way it's been
built up is so realistic and you could
see some kind of parallels to the real
world and how seriously politics is no
that's that's that's that's the reason I
got invested in the world of Game of
Thrones and that's the reason I really
still enjoyed the later Seasons it's
because you got to see different aspects
of this world collide together and I
just you know when you've when you've
watched enough things I've you just come
to realize you I know all my tastes are
you know I can still appreciate good
television but I know what core elements
appeal to me and there are more core
elements that appeal to me in the later
seasons of Game of Thrones even if it
was more messily executed and I've just
come to value that more and I feel like
there are a lot of shows out there there
are a lot of I mean I [ __ ] like I
thought of course I would say this I
[ __ ] like isekai right but like but
like I'm sorry but like there are enough
games enough shows enough movies that
are out there that might not be
perfectly executed might not have the
best execution but I still on a personal
enjoyment level still really really like
even more so than maybe some critically
you can't clip critically Acclaim shows
in that same genre yeah because if to me
like if I were to use like an anime
analogy for me as someone who's never
seen Game of Thrones it sounded like it
started off as like you know the the
political fantasy and you know very
nuanced type of heavily detailed world
of something like Kingdom yeah and then
went to something like fairy tale yeah
yeah it went it went where it's like
nothing makes sense but the main guy
wins and there's lots of big fights it's
just like it's insane when you when you
watch uh or you read about how you know
very subtle things have happened in the
show you're like this is insane like the
level of detail yeah yeah and and
thought that's put into how all of these
worlds and characters interact is just
insane yeah
um it's Kingdom to fairy tale yeah it's
it's genuinely Game of Thrones turned
into a showing it yeah from the sounds
of it yeah it's probably why I enjoy it
but hopefully he finishes the books
I mean like I would still have preferred
the later Seasons with all these
elements complied into me with the same
nuances of like that would be in the
perfect world right but I still go I
still got what I wanted and I was
entertained thoroughly
um and you know I was just I was just
thinking is this really hotter than my
bread take you nice yes
I'm just like oh all I was trying to say
is I have my own [ __ ] yeah you have
to understand right I think the Game of
Thrones ending in final season was like
one of the biggest betrayals of like TV
to the fan base more than Game of
Thrones it's very on brand yeah right
like it's literally on Brad like can you
think of a TV show that burned its fan
base harder like I I genuinely can't
like I can't think of anything that is
up to was that hyped it was that big of
a deal that [ __ ] up that bad
like no no fairy tale no they [ __ ]
still love it
plenty of shows go to shits are you okay
not on the scale that Game of Thrones
did it right this was like a you know
everything it did literally it was like
a day and night difference it was like
it went from everybody loves this [ __ ]
to now everyone in the western world was
talking about yeah yeah it was Non-Stop
and it also just goes to show clearly
how impactful that was that when yeah
they were able to green light so many
spin-offs that you know even though
everyone was like Game of Thrones
[ __ ] sucks that when they brought out
this new prequel that they shovel shoved
way too much [ __ ] money into the the
moment the first episode dropped
everyone was like hype
it's so good everyone get back on this
it's actually hype it's actually good
and to be fair the first season was
[ __ ] amazing they only have like one
book um to work off of and it's finished
the story is completely done yeah but
they're gonna make like three or four
seasons from just one book
um and it's insane like even the George
RR Martin has said that some of the
characters in the TV show are portrayed
better in the TV show than in his mind
on the book oh wow he's like he uh
there's a character in particular that
was done really well
and he said like I wish I could go back
and redo those pages now I wish I could
take them out because it's so much
better on TV it's so so so so so good
please if if you got burnt on Game of
Thrones give House of dragon a shot it's
so worth your time it's so good yeah
it's probably one of my favorite like
first seasons of TV in a long time wow
all right yeah I mean I I will finish it
so so good it's I I will I will reserve
my opinion I'm sure everyone's raring to
hear my opinion on House of dragons it
comes back later
I'm gonna kill you gone if they added
some more armor then I would have liked
it